a deadly crime spree starting in texas
running through nevada and ending in
arizona is now over
and the suspects in custody this
happened thanksgiving day with shootings
all across henderson
including at a 7-eleven store at lake
mead parkway and center street joe
muller unravels the story and brings us
an update on multiple victims
the people involved allegedly shot at
nearly a dozen people that morning the
7-eleven store behind us here on lake
mead parkway was turned into a crime
scene
on thanksgiving day a total of four
people were shot here one of them did
die here
is a memorial that's growing outside the
7-eleven store
22-year-old kevin mendiola jr was shot
and killed
as these candles continue to flicker the
questions surrounding a deadly shooting
linger
thanksgiving day the 7-eleven store in
henderson was surrounded with caution
tape after
shots rang out in a police report
obtained by 8 news now monday we learned
more about what happened
police identified three suspects as
shawn and christopher mcdonald
and kaylee lewis whose mug shot we also
obtained from the arresting agency in
arizona according to the report all
three were in a black sedan with texas
plates that morning
they were driving in the henderson area
and randomly shooting at people in their
cars
after shooting at several drivers the
three eventually came to this 7-eleven
where
they shot four people mandiola was
killed
the others were taken to the hospital
two of them were with mendiola at the
time
after the store shooting police say they
fled down lake mead parkway and shot
someone else in a car
that victim went to the hospital as well
hundreds of miles away
later that day they were all allegedly
involved in an officer-involved shooting
in arizona
and that is where they were taken into
custody one of the suspects was flown to
a hospital
why they were all allegedly shooting at
random people is still not known
police were able to match descriptions
from witnesses to security cameras
police say they believe christopher
mcdonnell is the one responsible for
mandiola's death
is now facing an open murder charge with
a deadly weapon reporting in henderson
joe muller 8 news now